it was here in wuhan a year ago china
first reported cases of pneumonia from
an unknown cause
and in january it was the first place to
go into a strict and sweeping lockdown
but was it where it all began the world
health organization
is sending investigators to china to
find out
our understanding at this time is that
china is welcoming
the international team and their visit
and that this is anticipated
as far as we are aware to happen in
early january
most experts believe the virus
originated in animals and spread through
this wet market in wuhan
but china has strongly opposed calls for
an international inquiry
into how the pandemic began saying it
felt unfairly targeted
chinese state media have suggested
covert 19
existed abroad long before it was
discovered in wuhan
since the outbreak of the pandemic china
has acted in an open
transparent and responsible way we
started cooperating with the who on
origin tracing very early on
the who experts have come to china twice
and chinese experts also held many video
conferences with the who personnel and
international experts the search for the
source of covert 19 has fueled political
tensions
u.s president donald trump accused china
of a cover-up
australia called for an investigation
into the virus's origins
which soured trade relations with china
but the world health organization
says its trip is not to apportion blame
but gather data to prevent future
outbreaks
wuhan residents are welcoming the
scrutiny
we all know that it is a seafood market
where it was first discovered
but it is highly possible that it came
from elsewhere and then ended up at the
market
seafood doesn't come from wuhan you know
perhaps there are even some deeper
origins prior to wuhan that need to be
looked into
for the 11 million people in wuhan life
is largely back to normal
they haven't had a locally transmitted
case since may
but for most of the rest of the world
life is anything
but normal millions are suffering locked
down
and wondering how this all began and
more importantly
when it will end charlotte ballas al
jazeera